this always makes me giggle but Netflix
put out a video a couple years ago
titled lady Danbury is a total effing
badass how would you describe her I mean
I think they say it pretty well I think
she's well I would say now knowing her
backstory I would say she's a total
effing Dynamic badass
okay so what makes you describe it that
way I think you get to see her grow into
that badassery you know she didn't
always start out that way so to see this
vulnerable woman who is essentially
like complacent to everything
churn and like become into this
extremely powerful magical being is it
makes her Dynamic I think
I love that answer no but I completely
agree with you and how would you
describe the importance of the
relationship between lady Danbury and
Queen Charlotte I would say it's
extremely extremely important because it
kind of highlights the balance that
Charlotte needs in her life you know it
shows that while a romantic relationship
fills you in one way a platonic
relationship fills you in a completely
other way and both are very necessary to
I don't know leading an authentic
understanding of The Human Experience
um and I think just the fact that
they're both black women being friends
is such a visually revolutionary image
so yeah it's extremely important
I love that uh you know Queen Charlotte
gets thrust into this arranged marriage
your character is in an arranged
marriage if you were forced into an
arranged marriage with one
characteristic or quality you would want
in a partner
understanding
oh that's a good one why understanding I
feel like it covers a lot of other
characteristics you know if you're
understanding you're empathetic if
you're understanding your kind you know
I mean I could I ca I don't think I
could be with somebody who's funny and
mean but I could be with somebody true
you know I could be with somebody who's
not funny but understanding because then
I could be the funny one
yeah I love that
um is this one of your first acting
roles because I read that and I was like
no way yeah I the only other role that
I've ever like been paid for was like
just as an extra on a Christian movie so
this is like my first actual thing yeah
I'm sorry your first big acting role is
in the Bridgerton Universe with Shonda
Rhimes I know pinch me I please someone
pinch me
right when has this whole experience
been like for you and you has changed
you
I mean I think
it's made me really have to hammer down
who I our semi am so that I try to not
let like everything like that's
happening change me in a negative way
you know so it means that I've like
become a lot more honest with myself
um and really relying finally on my
support system
um yeah but also like I've stolen a lot
of things from from this character you
know her confidence the fact that she
takes like a beat before she says
something you know she plays more of an
observer role and I tend to be like the
active person so I'm trying to you know
find a good median between our summer
and Agatha
oh my God I love that answer look you're
so good in this I I like I love Richard
Tim but I like I really love this series
so congratulations thank you so much
thank you
I just like to Sean Rhymes it's really
interesting you know obviously she
loves what she does and she talked about
how much love and attention she gave to
really crafting this relationship
between Grimsley and Reynolds
Freddie what do you love about this
connection between these two characters
um I think the greatest joy as an actor
to to play well firstly it's it's the
love that exists between them that was
it was brilliant exploring that and they
hold such a deep affection and care and
love for each other that was amazing but
also it was made more amazing because it
was
um in conflict with the duty that they
both felt towards their respective you
know for me the king and for some the
queen um so playing with
with that conflict is like what can
Reynolds share what can Brimley share
with with his loved one about you know
what was going on yeah 100
uh Sam it was really just really learned
that you can kind of made this pack for
YouTube we're going to spend time
outside of being on set together to
really kind of grow this friendship and
and so that we could see on camera this
chemistry that it's real so what did you
guys end up doing together well I mean
after the first time we met which is in
our first rehearsal uh we we went to we
went to the pub we had we shared like
stuff about ourselves over pints and um
and then we'd hang out with Corey and
India as well and just yeah we'd get to
know each other we had like six weeks
before we started shooting I think so we
we bonded over that period of rehearsals
and tried to hang out as much as we
could outside of work just uh
you know I've become as closer friends
as we have become and I now see all of
these guys as as very very close friends
and I think that chemistry just makes
the work so much easier and so much
better
you're pretty what's the best thing you
learned about Sam oh the best thing just
uh
surprising or weirdest things
no the the best thing I've learned about
is
um
he's one of the most generous kind
natured people I've ever had the
privilege of meeting
and I mean that from the bottom of my
heart that's very sweet yeah very sweet
I didn't know I could be so nice neither
did I
one question at a time
okay say I'm not gonna ask you the
question
um
yeah I mean I look I I I I I entirely
feel the same but it's it's I I feel
like now I mean I've I've got very close
friends but there's not a point in the
day of because we've shared a lot over
the past year
um that at any point I I need someone to
talk to about something this man will
always pick up the phone I mean it's
it's extraordinary I've never had a
friend that will pick up the phone come
what may
um so yeah I say that's it's because
I've got nothing else to do
I'm kidding I
yeah okay so look Queen Charlotte is
thrust into this
um arranged marriage so if you had to be
forced into an arranged marriage what is
a quality if you could choose that you
would look for in a potential partner
oh man
um humor
yeah I think I think that's the humor is
the key to a long-lasting brilliant
relationship yeah I think and uh for me
Integrity humor's so important but
Integrity is a big quality for me yeah
I like that too is it cool just being
part of the Bridgerton Universe yeah
it's
it's like I believe it's happening yeah
we still can't quite believe it's
happening and it's been happening since
last year yeah it's the most
overwhelming and exciting and wonderful
thing yeah yeah you guys are just way
cooler now you know like you were here
now you're up here well still incredibly
uncool
I'm gonna go with no on that but
interview you guys have been really fun
thanks so much thank you so much have a
good one